we've seen how important insects are as
a food source for many different animals
but insects are also important as food
for people
for people from North America or Europe
the idea of eating insects may seem
strange or even objectionable
but for more than two billion people
around the world insects are simply part
of their diets
in my travels I've had many
opportunities to eat insects
in a Market along the Amazon River in
Peru I tried roasted Palm Weevil grubs
in Venezuela I found a hot sauce made
from Ant Queens reported to be an
aphrodisiac
in Mexico I snacked on fried crickets
and sauteed ant larvae
in my experience eating insects isn't
just a novelty to experience as a
traveler it's a way of connecting with
the local culture and besides they're
tasty
insects have been a part of many
Cuisines for centuries insects may have
even played an important role in the
evolution of our species
one of the most important steps in the
evolution of humans was an increase in
brain size
as our ancestors brains became larger
there was a need for more calories in
the diet because the brain Demands a lot
of energy
animal protein is a rich source of
energy but hunting game isn't always
reliable
early hominid Hunters might have come
home with an antelope or elephant from
time to time but they probably couldn't
depend on meat from Big Game animals on
a daily basis
foraging for fruits nuts and other
edible plant parts is a more reliable
way to find food but plants aren't as
rich in energy and often lack essential
nutrients like protein and iron
insects may have provided the ideal
solution to the energy and nutrient
needs of early humans
insects are abundant especially in
tropical regions like the African
savannas where most of human evolution
occurred
early humans probably ate lots of
different types of insects from beetle
larvae to locusts
but social insects like ants and
termites were likely among the most
important insects in their diets
because they live in nests that can
contain thousands of individuals a nest
of ants or termites can be a very
reliable source of food concentrated
into a small area
chimpanzees our closest living relatives
are known to eat ants and termites
young chimpanzees learn to eat termites
by watching older chimps make a simple
tool out of a stick by stripping away
the leaves and side branches
they then insert the stick into a hole
in a termite nest in just the right way
so that the termites grab or bite the
stick
when they pull it out the stick is
covered in termites and the chimp
happily laps them up
1.8 million year old tools made of bone
that have been found in South Africa are
thought to have been used by early
humans for collecting termites
the tools were made by a species of
hominin called paranthropus robustus a
member of the group known as the
australopithecines that were our
evolutionary cousins
the tools were made from animal bones
and are worn down at one end suggesting
that perhaps they had been repeatedly
stuck into termite nests the way that
modern chimpanzees use sticks
to determine if bone tools could be used
to collect termites anthropologists made
similar tools from animal bone and tried
collecting termites themselves
they found that the modern bone tools
were not only an effective way to
collect termites but that the tools they
made ended up with thin parallel grooves
just like the ancient bone tools
suggesting that they may indeed have
been used for collecting termites
another reason to believe that early
humans ate termites comes from chemical
analyzes of fossilized teeth
analyzes of the hominin teeth found at
the same site in South Africa where the
bone tools were found showed that 35 to
40 percent of their diet had a chemical
signature of grasses or sedges
grasses and sedges weren't commonly
eaten by early humans because they're
hard to digest
it's possible that the hominins were
eating insects that had eaten grass
which would give their teeth the same
chemical signature as if they had eaten
grass directly
even if they were eating some grasses or
sedges these plants contain
carbohydrates and minerals but not much
protein so the hominins would have
needed other foods to round out their
diet
chimpanzees can get about half of their
daily protein from ants and termites
which require a lot less effort to
collect than other sources of protein
especially meat
our species Homo sapiens evolved about
two hundred thousand to three hundred
thousand years ago until about ten
thousand years ago all humans were
hunter-gatherers and would have
regularly eaten insects
that means that for the vast majority of
our species history insects have been an
important part of our diets and as we'll
see they still are
insects continue to be eaten by many
modern hunter-gatherers
the San people of the Kalahari Desert in
southern Africa collect termites Hawk
moth caterpillars grasshoppers ants and
booprested beetle larvae
Australian Aboriginal tribes in the
Northern Territory eat termites ants and
beetle larvae
they also are especially fond of wickety
grubs the larvae of moths in the family
casade that live in acacia trees
the ache people of Eastern Paraguay
forage for beetle larvae especially Palm
weevils whose larvae live in the trunks
of palm trees
Palm weevils are also eaten by many
people in the Amazon rainforest such as
the hoti and yanomamo people of
Venezuela
interestingly rather than simply
collecting Palm weevils when they happen
to find them the hoti people use their
knowledge of The Beatles life cycle to
their advantage
they cut a palm tree and make a few
incisions into the trunk then leave it
on the forest floor
when they return two or three months
later the trunk will be filled with palm
Weevil grubs ready to harvest
but hunter-gatherers are by no means the
only people that eat insects today
many traditional Cuisines include
insects as important ingredients
and as interest in traditional foods has
grown insect-based dishes are making a
comeback
let's take a quick tour of some of the
ways that insects are eaten around the
world
the best known insect food of course is
honey
when you eat honey you aren't eating the
bees themselves but you are eating some
of their saliva
but bees are edible especially the
larvae which are a prized delicacy in
many places
after all you are what you eat and the
bee larvae only eat honey and flower
pollen so they're delicious
in Laos and Cambodia honey bee larvae
are eaten while still in their wax
honeycomb cells
the honeycomb is wrapped in banana
leaves and roasted over hot coals than
eaten whole
in Japan the Annual habo Festival is
centered on collecting and eating Yellow
Jacket wasp larvae there's also a
competition for the person that brings
in the heaviest wasp nest
as we saw in an earlier lecture
silkworms are raised for their silk in
parts of South and East Asia after
they've spun their cocoon and the long
silk strand is harvested the pupae can
be eaten
in Korea silkworm pupae are known as
biondegi and are a popular street food
they're also canned and sold at Korean
grocery stores around the world
Weaver ant larvae and pupae are also
eaten in China India the Philippines and
Papua New Guinea
the largest larvae in pupae are those
that would develop into queens and these
are considered the most desirable
the worker ants aren't often eaten
because the formic acid they produce
makes them taste very sour but they're
sometimes used as a condiment to provide
a citrus-like flavor
another condiment made from insects
comes from giant water bugs in Vietnam
and Thailand a sauce made from the
essence of giant water bugs is used to
flavor dipping sauces
the bugs themselves are also eaten whole
or ground up with other ingredients
in central and southern Africa mapani
worms are a popular food mopani worms
are the larva of an emperor moth gon
embracia bellina that often feed on the
leaves of the mopani tree
an estimated 9.5 billion mopani worms
are harvested each year
in some cities like Kinshasa the capital
of the Democratic Republic of Congo an
estimated 70 percent of the 15 million
inhabitants eat mopani worms
The Collection preparation and sale of
mapani worms is also an important part
of the economy and offers a way for many
poor rural families to make a living
Mexican Cuisine is rich in insects
especially in the southern Mexican state
of Oaxaca one of the most popular
oaxacan insect dishes is chapulines
grasshoppers seasoned with lime and
chilies and fried
they're usually eaten on a corn tortilla
as tacos topped with salsa or guacamole
but chapolinas are also great eaten by
the handful as a crunchy snack
Mexico City is a great place to sample
traditional dishes that include insects
at the Mercado de San Juan I had the
opportunity to try a sampler platter
consisting of chapulines Scorpion and
chicatanas leaf cutter in Queens
the insects were fried and then drizzled
with mezcal liquor chili powder and a
squeeze of lime juice and served on a
bed of sliced citrus fruits they were
absolutely delicious
another insect common in traditional
Mexican Cuisine is the Maguey worm it's
actually The larva of a butterfly known
as the tequila giant skipper this is the
famous worm sometimes found in a bottle
of tequila or more precisely Tequila's
smokier cousin mezcal
the original purpose of including a
maguey worm in a bottle of miscal was to
prove that the liquor was strong enough
to preserve The larva which would
quickly decompose if there isn't enough
alcohol
the female butterflies lay their eggs on
the agave plant which is what tequila
and mezcal are made from and the larvae
feed on Agave as they grow
so for Mezcal producers including a
maguey worm in your bottle is a way to
demonstrate the quality of your product
while also practicing Pest Control
Maguey worms are also fried and eaten as
tacos like chapolines and they're tasty
but I have to say my favorite insect
dish in Mexico City in fact one of my
favorite foods of all time was one I
first had at an upscale restaurant on a
patio overlooking the Aztec Ruins of the
templo mayor
the dish is called escamole and it's
sometimes described as Mexican caviar
escamoles are ant larvae the ants in the
genus lyomatopum often make their nests
in the ground beneath Agave plants
they're creamy white and shaped like
jelly beans but smaller
they were sauteed in butter and a
fragrant herb called episote and served
with corn tortillas and guacamole The
Taste was incredible rich and earthy
unfortunately the larvae aren't easily
preserved so they don't travel well
that means if you want to try escamoles
and I highly recommend that you do you
probably have to travel to Mexico
but many other insect foods are becoming
increasingly popular in the U.S Europe
and other Western countries
around the world high-end restaurants
are increasingly featuring insects on
their menus
noma in Copenhagen which has on multiple
occasions been named world's best
restaurant features locally foraged
Foods including insects
London's archipelago features the
opposite of local food with a global
menu that includes exotic ingredients
like kangaroo zebra and grasshoppers
with caramel mealworms for dessert
at one of my favorite restaurants in
Houston Sochi which highlights oaxacan
Cuisine you can order a delicious mole
sauce made from leaf cutter ant Queens
insects provide an exciting and diverse
opportunity for chefs looking to explore
new flavors
more than 1 900 different insect species
are eaten by people worldwide
by comparison people only eat a few
dozen species of animals and about 200
species of plants
while Farms that raise crickets
mealworms silkworms and other insects
have been around for Generations in Asia
the surge in interest in insects as
ingredients has led to new insect Farms
popping up in the United States and
Europe
you can now find roasted Crickets at
some American grocery stores or you can
order them online
I like to eat crickets roasted with a
little salt they're a lot like nuts
they're also really good if you toss
them with a little chili powder to give
them some spice
in addition to being tasty one of the
reasons why insects are such a valuable
source of food for people is that
they're very nutritious in general
insects are high in protein and rich in
vitamins and minerals like calcium iron
and zinc
to get an idea of how nutritious insects
are let's compare the nutritional
content of mealworms to that of beef
if we discard how much of their weight
comes from water the remaining weight of
beef is 55 protein whereas meal worms
are about 49 protein so they're very
close in protein content
if we look even more carefully mealworms
and crickets have proteins made of
different combinations of amino acids
some are considered essential because
our bodies can't make them so we have to
get them from our diets
isoleucine is an example of an essential
amino acid that is more abundant in
mealworms than beef 42 grams per
kilogram in mealworms versus 16 in beef
on the other hand some other essential
amino acids like lysine and methionine
are more abundant in beef than in
mealworms so we can't really say that
meal worms are any better or any worse
than beef as a source of protein
but meal worms have less fat only 35
percent compared to 41 percent for beef
yet mealworms are rich in the essential
fatty acids our bodies need
mealworms are comparable to beef in
terms of omega-3 fatty acids but meal
worms have nine times more omega-6 fatty
acids than beef
is often considered a valuable source of
minerals like iron potassium and zinc
but mealworms have just as much of these
minerals as beef
and mealworms have more vitamins than
beef with the exception of vitamin B12
because they're so nutritious some
people see a lot of potential to use
insects as nutritional supplements
Cricut powder is very high in protein
and can be used like whey protein which
is made from cow's milk to fortify
smoothies and other Foods
I've also used Cricut flour to make
protein-rich cookies
the Cricut flour adds a Nutty flavor
similar to walnuts my kids love them
crickets and other insects are also
being used to make energy bars
if the idea of having insects in your
food seems strange or upsetting you may
be surprised to learn that there are
already insects in many of the foods we
eat
many foods that are red like strawberry
ice cream or red velvet cake get their
color from a red dye called Carmine made
from cochineal Bugs as we've already
learned cochineal bugs feed on Cactus
and the karminic acid they produce has
been used for centuries as a natural dye
for textiles and ceramics
in 2012 there was a public outcry
against Starbucks when it became widely
known that their strawberry Frappuccinos
and other products were dyed with
cochineal
the company quickly switched to another
insect-free natural food dye
many candies like jelly beans candy corn
and some chocolates are coated in a
substance called confectioners glaze
that makes them shiny
confectioners glaze is made from shellac
a resin produced by larvae of the lack
insect caria lacca
these are scale insects in the super
family coxoidia related to cochineal
bugs
black insects are some of the most
bizarre looking of all insects they
produce a waxy resin as a way to protect
themselves from predators as they feed
on plant phloem with their piercing
sucking mouth parts
whereas male lack insects look like
fairly typical hemipterans female lack
insects lose many of their recognizable
body parts including legs eyes and
antennae you could easily mistake a
female lack insect for a blob of dried
plant sap
black insects are cultivated for their
resin with the greatest production
coming from India
lack insects naturally live in clusters
of thousands of individuals
in fact the word lack comes from a Hindi
word that means hundred thousand
the resin secreted by so many lack
insects forms a protective sheath around
a tree branch
this material is harvested and purified
into shellac which is sold and used as a
food glaze
in addition to being used to coat
candies shellac is also used as a shiny
wax on citrus fruits
shellac is also used in the
pharmaceutical industry as a coating on
some medications
having shellac on a pill slows the
release of the medication so that it can
be absorbed by the body over a longer
period of time
shellac is better known for its use as a
wood varnish it's commonly used on fine
wood furniture to protect the wood and
give it an attractive glossy shine
shellac is also part of some of our
favorite pastimes it can be found on the
lanes of bowling alleys the outer
coating of billiard balls and playing
cards it was used to make the first
phonograph records before being replaced
by vinyl
shellac was also used as a sealant and
as insulation in electrical wiring
while it may seem surprising that the
same substance used for all these
purposes can also be edible consider
this
shellac is natural non-toxic tasteless
odorless and biodegradable
another way you may already be eating in
sex without realizing it is in processed
foods produce and spices many of which
unintentionally contain parts of insects
the USDA puts limits on how many insect
Parts there can be in different types of
foods but the amounts that are allowable
may surprise you
a typical chocolate bar can have about
24 tiny bug bits hidden inside
a jar of ground cinnamon can have around
400 insect parts
10 grams of ground oregano can have up
to
1250 insect fragments
and in just 10 grams of hops an
ingredient in beer there can be as many
as 2 500 individual aphids
while these numbers may sound alarming
the fact is that having small amounts of
insects in our food doesn't do us any
harm
and the more we think of insects as
possible sources of food rather than as
contaminants the more potential there
will be for using insects as ingredients
in Western Cuisines much as they already
are in so many other cultures
one of the reasons that some people
consider insects to be the food of the
future is that they require much less
space and far fewer resources to grow
rearing livestock like cattle pigs and
chickens takes a lot of space
currently more than 70 percent of all
agricultural land is used to raise
livestock
and additional space is hard to come by
eighty percent of the deforestation in
the Amazon rainforest is to clear land
to raise cattle
in contrast raising insects requires
very little space so little in fact that
it can be done indoors which makes it
possible to raise insects as Livestock
in urban areas
cattle chicken pigs and livestock also
need water to drink
fresh water is a precious resource and
about 40 percent of the water we use
goes to livestock either for them to
drink or to water the plants we raise to
feed them
which reminds us that of course animals
raised as livestock have to be fed a lot
to get one kilogram of chicken you need
2.5 kilograms of feed
one kilogram of pork requires five
kilograms of feed
beef is the most resource demanding
animal protein to get one kilogram of
beef you need 10 kilograms of feed
by comparison to get one kilogram of
crickets requires just 1.7 kilograms of
feed
another benefit of raising insects for
food is that insects produce far fewer
greenhouse gases than other animal
livestock
cattle produce enormous amounts of
methane as a byproduct of the
microorganisms that help them digest
their food
methane is a more potent greenhouse gas
than carbon dioxide so raising cattle is
the greatest contributor to greenhouse
gas emissions of all agricultural
activity
altogether livestock contribute 18
percent of all greenhouse gas emissions
which is even more than transportation
most insects do not produce methane the
exceptions being termites and some
cockroaches
crickets produce minute amounts of other
greenhouse gases like ammonia
but compared to cattle and pigs crickets
produce about 100 times less greenhouse
gases
and that doesn't even include the
forests that don't have to be cut down
to make space for them
altogether the small space requirements
minimal water and feed requirements and
comparatively small greenhouse gas
emissions make insects perhaps the most
sustainable animal protein we currently
have available
if we ever establish human settlements
on the Moon Mars or other planets
insects may even be the only option for
animal protein for one thing insects fit
much more easily into a spacecraft than
say a cow
and with even more limited amounts of
water oxygen and food we wouldn't want
to be competing with big animals
there's another advantage to only
bringing insects as livestock for space
colonies we get a lot of infectious
diseases from animals when a virus or
other microbe switches hosts
the mammals and birds we raise as
livestock are similar enough to us that
the pathogens that infect them can
sometimes infect us too
but that's much less likely to happen
with microbes that infect insects
because insects are much more distantly
related to us than our birds and mammals
so by limiting our livestock to Insects
we can decrease the chances of future
disease outbreaks
even with all the environmental and
health advantages of eating insects and
the knowledge that many people around
the world eat insects on a regular basis
some people just can't bring themselves
to eat a bug
if you're one of these people I'd like
to challenge you to reconsider the idea
of insects as food
after all is eating a cricket or a meal
worm really all that different from
eating a shrimp or an oyster
so much of what we think of as edible
comes down to what we were brought up to
consider normal food
if you grew up in Oaxaca grasshoppers
would be just another option for what to
put in your taco
if you were raised in Korea then you
might see silkworm larvae as comfort
food
perhaps future Generations around the
world and even those living on other
worlds will all consider insects as an
essential part of their diets